you know as recently as 1910 or so
rudolph otto who was a great
philosopher of religious experience he
defined god as
the holy and totally other
well to somebody raised on tabloid
newspapers and 50s science fiction
the wholly totally other sounds much
more like invaders from the rim
than anything associated with the
judeo-christian
tradition somehow in the same way that
we have disney fied
the elves we've actually disney fied
god too and and so the
you know the old-fashioned phrase god
fearing
it has a very uh anachronistic
ring we modern people don't
fear god we deconstruct god
we may seek god as
spiritual counselor and friend
if we're you know god positive
people if we're god negative people we
deny the very phenomenon
but very f but if you spoke of
being god fearing some people i think
would think you must be
amish or mennonite or something it's
such an
old-fashioned emotion uh
the alien that comes through
uh the psychedelic experience is
terrifying in its aliens in and
of itself it isn't that it does anything
terrifying or that it
promises a threat it's simply that
its existence inspires an
awe which mutates into terror
because it so
um turns on and
all cultural values in a way you could
almost say that
that culture is a defense against
the sense of this thing the holy and
totally
other which which is there
and when culture fails when culture has
nothing more to say to you
such as when you're on your death bed
and
you know what's being sold down at the
market no longer has any interest
for you and what's on tv seems
irrelevant
because you're going to die in the next
hour in other words once you move beyond
cultural values then this terror
this awesome thing waits it also
attends birth you know in but only
momentarily because as soon as soon as
it's determined that you're alive
basically
as an infant being born you're folded
into the
mechanisms of the waiting culture
so very rarely do we come nakedly
against uh this thing which is
there all the time i maintain the reason
it happens
with a drug like dmt is because what
drugs really do
is dissolve this cultural illusion
they dissolve it so thoroughly that then
this other thing which we've forgotten
can rush in i've noticed
i may be susceptible to this but it does
get described in
the psychological dictionaries of
pathology
but i'm susceptible and i always have
been
to i suppose you would call it a form of
hysteria
but it's fear in wilderness places
and uh
if you have this you know exactly what i
mean if you don't have it you it just
seems like some kind of pathological
weirdness but
it happens when you are alone in
wilderness
in other words when there is nobody
there expressing cultural values
uh there's it's a it's a recognized
phenomenon of the human condition
uh there's a
there's an anthropology book about a
tribe in
new in sumatra the tambunan
the subtitle of the book is
something like the felt presence of the
other in the extra community context
and it talks about how another name for
it is windigo
psychosis the wendigo this is more
spectacular form
this is something that happens in the
north woods of canada
where people who are out in these
extreme wildernesses
become convinced that they're being
stalked by
this animal which is a supernatural
animal
the windigo and the indians know
this thing and they fear it it's sort of
like the sacha mama
idea in the amazon it's an enormous
beast that is so is more feared by the
people
than anything making it onto the
discovery channel you know
they can handle anacondas they can
handle jaguars but the windigo and the
sacha mama
are beyond you know the hunter's skill
the shaman's power it's something uh
overwhelming and i think that part of
the consequences of
scientific materialism and
existentialism
is to place us into an extracultural
environment
and then we become we are afraid of
you know something strange that comes
from the sky
that is so intimately hostile
that it you know wants to look up our
rear ends and
trade our fetal tissue and
you know mess with us in in ways which
aren't rational if it's a
you know a true species come from
another star
system i don't think they'd start the
contact with the human race by checking
us all for hemorrhoids that doesn't
that doesn't feel right uh
so it's something else then it's
something else and
and it is a template of our fears
our fears of being penetrated in a
perverse
manner that's basically what's going on
there our
fears of of uh having our genetic
material
tampered with that's what the fetal
tissue trading is all about
our fears of having our humanness
compromised i think i mean it is in a
sense a true booking man
it's pure unadulterated fear
the the aliens of popular culture
the grays the slanted
all this zoo of things that haunt the
tabloids
are very different from the the dmt
creatures who are much more similar to
the earth centered
supernatural beings like fairies elves
gnomes nixies sprites our freits
gins tree spirits uh who all
have a morbid quality i mean they all
enchant in some way and
lead astray but it's not a planetary
invasion and it's not and it doesn't
have
these sexual overtones of sexual anxiety
that seem to attend this this other
thing
bottom line i think being alive is a
very interesting situation
but only if you pay attention you know
otherwise it tends to drift into the
background
and something else takes its
place our circumstance is extraordinary
even measured against the existence of
animal life on this planet
our situation is extraordinary and a
mind
is a very dynamically
chaotic undefined
thing still more you know the group mind
of a species the nature of information
is not understood the nature of this
thing coordinating all this information
which we call the human soul
is not very uh well understood
the one of the fallacies that haunts
clear
thinking is the is the fallacy of the
mundane
there really is no mundane i mean
when you start deconstructing things
everything uh be it turns out
mystery stands behind the simplest
phenomena the simplest act
its kazooistry reaches back
eons of time its implications spread out
through
the universe and you know who is witness
to all of this simply the unaided human
mind
trying to struggle forth forward toward
a model of itself and a model of the
world
that it's embedded in and culture
even the culture of science or the
culture of mathematics
where it pretends to build firm ground
there is in fact really only uh
quicksand
or at the very best the kind of bridges
that occur
in in uh
sir the lane and the green night and the
knights of the round table the kind of
bridge that you can
ride a horse across
before the bridge burns and tumbles into
the abyss
but that's all you can move across
i mean we're constantly living like that
you know
think how many of us are dead almost all
of us
are dead at any given time i don't mean
this in a gergie fiance or metaphorical
sense i mean that 99.99
of all human beings who ever lived are
now dead
the living portion of mankind is a thin
sliver compared to all who have come and
gone
over the past three or four million
years
so the enterprise of understanding
which seems to rest with with the living
inherits a huge momentum from these
people who've gone
before i mean the the
the dynamic tension or the
interest in life at least for me
is in trying to be a human being
to whatever degree that's possible and
then also
trying to understand it all from the
outside
trying to be you know both fully human
and somehow fully extra environmental
extra human
my mother for god knows what reasons
because it didn't
particularly lie in her background or
education
uh named me after a roman poet
and this roman poet was a fairly minor
character and he wrote these sort of
fosh little
social comedies these plays
but one quote survives from the roman
poet terence
he said uh i am a human being
and therefore nothing human is
alien to me
and the you know the dilemma of our
moment in modernity i think
in terms of these whisperings from the
other is to decide
that uh nothing human
is alien to us and that all aliens
have one foot in humanness
you